hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham
episode 7 video is titled Penguins
Umbrella but
pictures ass was like the big new
character they introduced
both he and the pain when got amazing
teens
the ringtone and as his phone was funky
town in the pain we got its original
score that sounded something like a
twist on the Sherlock beam from the BBC
Sherlock
I'm anything given is like keeping with
tradition at the game is on Team
there's also some really cool news about
new Batman villains the show's gonna
bring on in the second half saltzman at
the end of the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet but starting with top by
moment
number five Gordon has a plan it may not
sound like a very good plan
in ultimately it really didn't go down
the way he expected but I do have to
give them a hat tip for having the balls
to March
into tacones home with a machine gun if
you confused about what the actual plan
was supposed to be
use gonna rest everyone associated with
the Arkham City Development
the mir falcone Maroni eventually fish
Mooney
pretty much all the high-ranking
mobsters I wasn't quite sure a bullock
was gonna go along with it
when he brought the hooker the night
before everything went down I kept
expecting something to go sideways
still feel like Bullock is on Falcons
take there's a plan within the plan with
the pain when
there's gotta be something going on with
Bullock to number four
my tween Christmas apologized it in
completely addressed the fact that might
we tried to steamroll Gordon
based on the way the lettings I think
gordon's call with them I don't think
he's gonna punch in the face or anything
he even told Bruce that they would take
over his parents case if something
happened to him
that was one of the scenes I felt they
could have gotten rid up Bruce
crying and hugging cordon I feel like
they didn't need that
other atty give us the chance to see
Alfred in action
he is a badass I'm way for him to punch
someone in the face if you like Sean
Pertwee
would be amazing in a fight even if he's
not a huge guy I just feel like
the legend Alfred should be a thing I'm
interested to see if they go
a question route with my toys characters
then she becomes the question in the
comics
but that's only after she hits rock
bottom in his just season one so it's by
can be a long time before anything like
that happens
number three the Arkham City Development
is good to go
I can explain that everything is poised
to begin with the Arkham City
construction
when it's going to be is just a cash cow
for the mob that is going on all that
real estate
so all the businesses everything that
goes there all the catch the comes
through
they're going to get kinda that those
with the bargaining was for the
waterfront real estate
whenever the penguin suggested the offer
up that waste dump the falcone
and a lot you're wondering if that's
going to be some sorta Solomon Grundy
teaser
I think there is something there I mean
think about it warehouse built
on an Indian burial ground near a
madhouse what could possibly go wrong
they have been introduced a whole lot of
people associated with Arkham yet along
the Batman don't that they've already
confirmed to bring on like you to a
strange
so I think we'll see then the second
half of the season
I do think we'll see a fully operational
Arkham Asylum before the end of season
one
the B twenty episodes total so that's a
long ways off number two
meet victors ads if you guys didn't
recognize him his name in real life is
Anthony kerrigan
a couple weeks ago he played count
members on the flash
that's the mist character so is it a
funny coincidence that these
leapfrogging from DC character to DC
character
the victors as we're meeting is
obviously a prequel to the one we'd see
when a fully developed Batman services
he originated in the comics in 1992
if you noticed he was carving marks on
his arm this is when the trade marks in
his character
he keeps tally for all the people the
murders that's why wouldn't be seen in
the Batman comics he's
covered in Mark's I got them here since
that like 10 years away
obviously he hasn't killed as many
people yet the way his character's
explaining the comics
is the he believes life is pointless in
that would he kill someone
he's freeing them from a meaningless
existence is mostly known for killing
young women
but he will kill anybody he does use the
show up in most in the big Batman
productions like the cartoons
or the video games see a pricey min
arkin night whenever the game's release
next year
I thought the actor had an interesting
presents on screen he didn't get that
many scenes
the police station was really his big
moment isn't it funny how quickly the
police cleared the room
is a very different got and the time a
Batman even the captain don is crazy the
corn even came to work that day
in whenever one moment the penguin in
falcone's plan
revealed everyone is it the chicken dip
Alco now he's got his eyes on Arkham
City that's all he cares about
it seems like all the stuff that's
happening with the penguin Gordon
fish Mooney and everyone else is just
amusement for him
the speech he gave to cordon about order
and chaos is very important
it's almost like he was giving the
prequel for what happened during the
Christian on Dark Knight trilogy
the mob in Falcon provide a certain
level aboard in the chaos
when she get rid of them the crazies in
the masts prior to the woodwork
I think that's just what docking was
talking about like he knows
the if he's not around things will get
really crazy
he is an evil dictator we gonna take
what he says with a grain of salt
just hold out no 10 years Batman to be
here he'll bring order
here's a couple things i'm looking for
to now that we know doc who knows
about pretty much everything that's
going on one he's totally gonna slice
the Russian up
if you notice he's getting careless in
Falcons presence like he was grabbing
moonies but
clearly he's gonna die really soon do
you think it's mid
very big character obviously she's gonna
weasel her way out somehow they're not
going to kill her off
and he's not to the end a season one
even then anything's up for grabs
just expect her to talk really really
fast and say something really convincing
to keep yourself alive
going back to gordon if you member
Falcone said that he had a relationship
with jordan's father
be really interested to see if he
important kinda develop something on the
side
Gordon is the white knight who got them
right now so I don't think he's going to
be making any deals with any doubles
anytime soon but he is being forced into
relationships like this
that he is going on with the pain when
is the best example that
whenever he said Gordon will see the
light eventually all I could think about
was born in with the bat signal just
flipping it on
so the big thing we need to start
focusing on is Arkham City
if you like the show's gonna go to that
place more and more as we get closer to
the end to the season
or even the midseason finale other
places in Gotham City they can tell
stories on this show
if you like Arkham is going to be the
most exciting in most rewarding for us
as viewers
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and what do you
think
Vickers ads overall again the absurd
assault B-plus
to Leila pictures as as I mentioned it's
not like he did a good job
owning the room without overdoing it
kinda feel like you to pick it Smith
does that just a little bit
like her character is just a little over
the top if you're trying to place all
these characters
you know you have Tim Burton's Batman
movies you had the classic sixties TV
show
if you like she's in the classic sixties
TV show everyone else is new Tim Burton
movies
in terms the Arkham story if you like
obviously that's the thing the show's
building towards
it there trying to hit that by episode
10 I do feel like they're on track
to face is actually coming on the show
really soon so I'll be looking forward
to that
and is it going to be a very young
virgin a party Dan and I do not think
he's gonna turn it to face into the
episodes
would you see the coin flip that's all
all the versions the den the character
in the comics
in the animated series in the crisper
known movies the coin flip
was always a big thing even before he
became too Faced in speaking about me
and on
here's the big news the just-announced
they're going to bring scarecrow on
the way they're doing is they're going
to introduce him as a kid
pick somewhere near brusett pipes a
little bit older but
he will eventually take the mantle a
scarecrow from his father
they haven't asked anyone for you the
father or the John think ring character
but we do know that the father will be
in enemy and importance that will be
someone the corn is chasing down
depending on how old the actor is that
they cast for John think rain
I think we might get to see him play
with the scarecrow mask a little bit
and he's a little bit imagery not to
start look for to but let me know if
there's any the pentagon's the guys
really wanna see
who do you think that they should bring
on and a lot of people want Solomon
Grundy to come especially with all the
toxic waste dump stuff happening around
Arkham
so next week is going to be are Harvey
Dent episode it's actually called the
mask which
you know obviously commune everything's
black mask Batman mask
so many masks got them be sure to
subscribe to get my be opposite right
after the episode airs
in the meantime if you get 78 you can
click here might happen deficit sex
video
in you can click here for me episode 5
video thank you so much for watching
thought I'd like to see you guys
tomorrow